[Musique]
depuis quelques jours une téléréalité au
concept plutôt simple fait le buzz sur
Netflix
adapter d'un format américain ce
programme accueille 6 couples dans une
situation particulière l'un des
partenaires veut se marier l'autre pas
du tout le mariage me dégoûte en
participant à cette émission de
plusieurs épisodes les tourtereaux vont
se voir poser un ultimatum accepté de se
marier ou se séparer pour les aider à
prendre cette grande décision ils vont
d'abord fréquenter pendant plusieurs
semaines une autre personne vous allez
constater par vous même si l'herbe est
plus verte ailleurs
un concept diabolique qui rend
aujourd'hui complètement fou les
spectateurs je viens de commencer
ultimatum c'est quoi cette dinguerie
c'est la nouvelle île de la tentation
des candidats de cette nouvelle
télé-réalité témoigne ce soir dans TPMP
[Applaudissements]
et Lina sont avec nous merci squatellina
ça va oui ça va tranquille alors Scott
toi tu es arrivé dans l'émission avec
l'Insee une jeune femme de 24 ans avec
qui tu es en couple depuis 5 ans et demi
à faire l'émission j'ai pas hésité parce
que l'émission le but c'est vraiment de
savoir si à l'heure actuelle on a
vraiment trouvé la femme qui est qui est
faite pour la vie et donc quand m'a
proposé ce concept j'ai tout de suite
foncé parce que j'avais un vieux doute
je suis quelqu'un
j'avais pas de doute mais je perds pas
de temps moi j'ai besoin de savoir où je
vais avec qui je vais et savoir si
sont là quoi alors parce qu'en fait
l'Insee avec toi mais toi tu trouvais le
mariage
tu trouvais que ça n'avait aucun intérêt
et donc elle t'a posé un ultimatum soit
Marie soit tu te sépare tu es amoureux
d'elle quand même très amoureux si après
ça un an et demi je suis pas amoureux si
tu voulais pas te marier c'est voilà tu
avais pas envie de non me marier je suis
pas je suis pas pour le mariage je suis
désolé mais moi je suis bon après voilà
j'ai eu à passer donc je sais que le
mariage ça fonctionne pas en tout cas de
de ce que j'ai vécu déjà été marié mais
une question ça arrivera avec lui
si on commence à taper les invités déjà
qu'on les insulte c'est bon tu lui mets
un coup comme ça
tu étais mariée toi
les gars viennent l'autre
jamais marié non mais un qui pète
l'hôpital
[Rires]
vendredi mais quand même
moi je trouve très sympathique squat en
tout cas je suis un petit coup de cœur
pour lui merci
pour toi ah mais je te jure vraiment si
je te jure je t'adore vous avez donc ta
candidature ta candidater on est venu te
chercher on est venu me chercher quand
on est venu me chercher sur les réseaux
ce que voilà j'ai un peu je sais pas un
petit peu de notoriété vraiment minime
[ __ ] tu es un personnage tu es sympa
et puis tu trouves bah oui moi je te
prendrai dans un casting direction bah
vas-y propose-moi quelque chose
[Rires]
on a été défrayé oui c'est normal ah oui
c'est normal bien sûr combien ça ne te
regarde pas
alors on va faire on va revenir dans 2
secondes
on va revenir dans deux secondes
là-dessus et tu vas nous dire ce qui
s'est passé un peu parce que je veux
savoir si Elina pareil Lina elle est
arrivée avec Sofiane
un homme de 31 ans avec qui tu étais en
couple depuis 2 ans et c'est vrai que
toi aussi tu as vécu l'aventure tu vas
nous raconter dans un instant c'est vrai
que cette histoire il faut aller vous
venez me dire si vous trouvez ce concept
intéressant pas ou si vous trouvez que
ça va trop loin voilà Gilles toi je sais
que tu le ferais jamais parce que
peut-être que c'est peut-être le moment
de le faire avec Fatou
[Rires]
la meuf de Gilles donc toi tu as
participé à l'émission si vous nous
rejoignez cette émission qui fait
énormément parler en fait le concept
c'est un
ultimatum avec ta meuf ou ton mec depuis
quelques temps et on te dit voilà c'est
où tu te maries ou tu te fiances ou bien
ça se termine et tu vas passer du temps
avec une personne que tu as choisie
donc c'est six couples qui reçoivent
la personne tu l'as choisi tu passes
trois semaines avec elle ça veut dire
que tu peux dire voilà une note c'est
une meuf voilà c'est une meuf avec qui
tu sens qu'il y a un petit bail Non toi
tu as choisi qui toi par exemple
j'ai choisi une des filles qu'on voit là
après je vais pas je vais pas vous dire
qui j'ai choisi sinon ça n'a aucun
intérêt à regarder
justement donc c'est le but aller voir
oui arrogant il y a beaucoup de gens il
y a beaucoup de gens qui sont énervés
contre toi
et moi tu sais ce que j'ai répondu
c'était un accident c'était un accident
c'est ce que j'ai dit tu vois je suis
venu en aide on m'a dit ouais truc hein
comment toi tu as pas été vous allez
voir si on Satis quand même t'as pas été
c'est pas ouf
non parce que lui alors moi j'ai une
question moi je suis fan de Scott c'est
mon héros donc Scott en fait il a il a
un peu merdé avec sa compagne et en fait
ce que je comprends pas dans l'épisode
c'est qu'à un moment vous parlez d'un
bisou après ça parle de message sur
Instagram et la fille en question
sous-entend que vous allez passer la
nuit ensemble donc ma question est
simple est-ce que tu as passé la nuit
avec elle est-ce que tu t'es régalé mon
[ __ ]
c'est un professionnel et toi qui aime
pas le mariage qu'est-ce que tu fous
dans cette émission
non mais c'est alors
oui c'est c'est vrai que moi j'ai vu les
images et c'est vrai que c'est un peu
flou genre on laisse planer le doute
ouais je vais dire quand il y a des
doutes il y a plus de doute hein
toujours pas toujours je vais te dire et
moi je serais toujours là pour toi c'est
gentil pour te sauver mais là tu me fous
dans la merde dans la merde je te le dis
tout beaucoup dans la merde tu vois
frérot juste oui non rien qu'est-ce que
tu penses moi j'aime pas du tout
l'émission
et j'ai absolument rien contre vous mais
je trouve que voilà comme la téléréalité
aujourd'hui elle est en bout de course
elle est au bout du rouleau elle essaie
de se réinventer
en avant un inventant un concept ou on
pousse encore un petit peu plus le
curseur un petit peu plus trash et moi
en fait ce qui me choque ça me choque
pas d'ailleurs ça m'a bien grand mot
mais ce que je trouve un peu dégueulasse
en fait c'est que en fait vous vous
voulez juste passer à la télé c'est un
programme de télé réalité en fait avoir
un propriétaire
sur le dos d'une
institutions à la limite il y aura un
projet mais là c'est exactement la même
chose
je peux lui répondre que déjà les
Marseillais Louison c'est
morte
parce que on va montrer l'extrait après
tu nous diras ce que tu penses
Jean-Marie mais justement montrer un
extrait de Scott dans l'émission et je
vous dis ça ça voilà ça ça c'est
l'avenir ça voilà ça c'est pas les
Marseillais les gens c'est fini ça ça
c'est terminé
eux ils vont faire ça
un truc énorme
on dit que c'est ça aujourd'hui le
projet de de j'ai raté
parce que
parce que j'ai pas j'ai pas tout tout
dit en fait c'est à dire qu'est-ce qu'il
y a en fait on s'est embrassé en fait
c'est une blague non
je te parle
c'est que pauvre type je te jure c'est
bon je me casse
[Musique]
ça c'est avec
moi j'ai capté en fait Scott ce que j'ai
capté toi tu es un amoureux de l'amour
c'est vrai j'ai capté regarde je vais te
montrer un extrait tu penses que tu
allais être d'accord avec moi
j'arrive pas à
envie de demander si romane elle veut
pas partir de l'appart et je prends le
riz avec moi
tu te mets dans une autre niveau de
problème toi eh mais toi mais tu dois te
manger des trucs tu te rends même pas
compte c'est ça qui est bien avec toi tu
es dans le moment présent tu sais ce
qu'on va faire on va aller revoir
l'ourrier romane et on va voir comment
ça va
pas du tout d'accord avec Géraldine je
trouve que je trouve que ce concept est
extraordinaire parce qu'il y a une
tension folle les enjeux sont dingues
évidemment
c'est une vie qui se joue un destin qui
se joue donc c'est extraordinaire et moi
j'ai une question à poser à Lina si vous
le permettez justement parce que Lina tu
tu tu tu l'as lâches 2 minutes déjà
qu'on a pas laissé parler une seconde on
l'a pas encore présenté elle va parler
après il faut que tu suives l'émission
Jean-Marie elle est arrivée dans
l'émission avec Sofiane un homme de 31
ans et qui était en couple depuis 2 ans
et c'est lui qui te pose un ultimatum
faites là c'est le c'est l'inverse
exactement toi tu as dit oui tout de
suite
pour oui tu l'as pas mal pris tout de
suite mais j'ai réfléchi et en fait on
avait une problématique assez
voilà on avait une problématique ou
Sofiane devait aller vivre aux
États-Unis vous voulez que je le suive
et Sofiane devait sentir dans les mois
qui suivaient et j'ai pris ça comme une
opportunité en fait de vraiment vivre
une expérience qui pourrait me conforter
dans mon choix en fait
ou pas je savais pas si j'étais prête à
tout quitter pour partir avec toi
j'ai compris
c'est que tu as pas ta langue dans ta
poche regarde 2 minutes
c'est pas compliqué
si j'avais pu lever
par rapport à ce que j'ai entendu par
rapport à ce qu'on a vu par rapport
vous êtes des enfants vous avez
quasiment tous 30 ans vous pouvez pas
juste considéré que deux personnes
s'entendent bien et même physiquement il
ne pleut pas je lui ai dit je lui ai dit
physiquement vous voyez bien il y a
aucun rapport pourtant il a bien dit
qu'il aurait pu juste Ken et c'est tout
hein moi il me l'a dit en face
ouais toi tu penses que voilà tu penses
qu'il aurait pu avoir alors
moi je me suis basée sur ce qu'on m'a
dit moi je me suis basée sur ce qu'on
m'a dit à ce moment-là oui Sofiane me
disait qu'il y avait qui avait un
feeling et qu'elle lui plaisait bien et
c'est bien ce que j'ai dit j'ai dit
Sofiane m'a dit s'il pouvait te il
aurait fait donc c'est pas ce que je
pensais c'est ce qu'on m'a dit aussi
il avait peur dans un autre contexte
c'est ça et en fait tu penses qu'il a
il faut voir les épisodes
je pense que le territoirement il
pourrait peut-être
je sais pas il faut lui poser la
question
pour moi ça c'est l'avenir de la télé et
je trouve qu'on retrouve la sincérité
des candidats il y a 20 ans pourquoi
parce qu'il y a un vrai jeu dans les
Marseillais dans les anges il y a pas
danger c'est trop l'enjeu c'est trouver
un taf bidon à Punta Cana là non pas du
tout Géraldine exactement
ils sont plus âgés c'est des vrais
couples on sent c'est ça on se met à
leur place il y a un vrai juste à savoir
s'ils vont se marier ou pas ça n'a rien
à voir il y a des vrais personnalités ça
fait longtemps qu'une émission avait pas
de sortie des stars des personnalités
comme ça et franchement pour moi c'est
ça l'avenir de la télé-réalité ça oui
non mais c'est vrai
j'ai j'ai du mal à comprendre comment
comment est-ce qu'on peut arriver à à
faire cette émission et comment je suis
désolé comment est-ce qu'on peut bah
voilà mettre son son couple du coup en
péril et moi je vais te dire la vérité
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de cette
manière
je peux rebondir bah c'est que il a
raison c'est-à-dire il y a suffisamment
d'occasion pour être on est dans un
couple d'accord et bien si je vais quand
même te raconter cette blague du garçon
il va voir son père il dit papa je veux
me marier son père il lui dit excuse-toi
et demande pardon elle dit papa je viens
juste de demander je veux me marier et
dit je te demande de t'excuser de
demander pardon demain il dit bon ben
pardon papa je m'excuse il dit bon c'est
bon tu peux te marier maintenant
au revoir bravo
ça veut dire que tu m'as interpellé
depuis tout à l'heure pour ça oui quand
tu es d'accord pour demander pardon même
si tu as raison je crois que tu es bon
pour le mariage c'est ça que ça veut
dire
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas de ma faute si vous n'avez pas
le quotient intellectuel moi j'ai
compris
alors Lina toi tu as vécu des moments
particulièrement compliqués pendant le
tournage tu as pleuré je me suis énervé
j'ai pleuré j'ai rigolé tu regrettes de
l'avoir fait ou pas on va voir les
extraits de l'avoir fait le bail pas du
tout pas du tout pas du tout attends
regarde peut-être après ça autre chose
que je fais tu pars en couille tu fais
des crises pour rien moi je fais des
cris tu fais un truc alors que je t'ai
prévenu à plusieurs reprises Sofiane tu
disparais de ma vie je ne fais pas des
crises d'hystérie
non mais c'est vrai que tu crois trop
que tu es la reine de d'Arabie Saoudite
ou je sais pas quoi que tu crois tout
permis en fait je suis tellement gentil
avec toi que tu crois que je suis faible
je crois je te le dis moi l'amour je
t'aime ouais mais l'amour je m'en bats
les couilles en fait du jour au
lendemain je me casse et j'en ai rien à
[ __ ]
il est en train vous comprenez ma blague
maintenant
[Rires]
c'est fou là c'est je sens remonter
quand même non je sens pas avoir une
énorme confiance
en Lui
vous savez dans ce genre de l'expérience
même je pense quand nous on a pu
confiance on apprend à se connaître de
base on vient pour une problématique de
couple et on commence à aussi se poser
des questions sur son couple et sur
nous-mêmes en même temps et du coup on
passe par différentes émotions bah là je
passe par la colère et par la tristesse
revoir les images bah parce que c'est
pas facile de se voir comme ça non mais
oui mais pardon
c'est pour ça que ce programme il est
fabuleux mais arrêtez je pense je pense
que vous êtes réactive à l'amour vous
aime l'amour justement
est-ce qu'on vient de voir des émotions
de Lina c'est la sincérité pure et c'est
le révélateur d'un couple cette émission
c'est pour ça que c'est un danger
terrible
alors moi j'adore l'émission et c'est
vrai que quand on aime l'amour quand on
aime les couples et les relations entre
les gens je pense que c'est hyper
intéressant et je pense aussi que quand
on peut être tenté par la tromperie
c'est que de toute façon le couple est
sur le déclin et si on a pas de se
marrer avec une personne au bout d'un
moment c'est qu'en fait on n'aura pas
plus envie dans quelques temps c'est
qu'il manque quelque chose donc ça sert
à rien
moi si c'est ça la télé de demain je
revends ma télé alors c'est pas là
c'est une belle télé les grands
[Applaudissements]
moi j'aime bien alors l'ultimatum en
amour on sait que ça ne marche jamais
faut pas mettre du petit matin c'est la
plus grosse des conneries moi je m'y
connais personne oubliés en revanche le
programme je l'aime bien parce que ça me
fait penser à l'île de la tentation deux
points 0 mieux que l'île de la tentation
on pourra on peut pas refaire lui de la
tentation aujourd'hui et si nous
peut-être qu'on n'aime pas ce programme
là c'est peut-être qu'on est peut-être
un peu largué peut-être que vous avez
marre mais peut-être pas la cible moi
non vous êtes gay là j'aime bien pardon
non mais 2 secondes je veux juste te
dire mademoiselle parce que je me trouve
absolument charmante et je ne remets
absolument pas en cause votre sincérité
dans ce programme en revanche vous êtes
un cobaye c'est à dire qu'en fait on
vous utilise on vous instrumentalise on
filme votre rupture on filme l'adultère
mais éventuellement
Géraldine à une personnalité folle enfin
non mais folle je trouve que c'est
discriminant pour elle de dire ça
est-ce qu'elle peut s'exprimer la Nina
j'ai vu là enfin on parle beaucoup de
tromperie on est venu voir si on est
aussi on va tromper ou etc en fait c'est
pas ça on est venu passer une expérience
avec des personnes qui sont complètement
différentes de notre conjoint ou notre
conjoint en fait donc moi par exemple
j'ai fait mon expérience avec quelqu'un
qui sur le papier me convenait un peu
plus que Sofiane et voir si avec ce
genre de personne je serai peut-être
plus heureuse mais à aucun besoin de la
caméra
est-ce que vous connaissez un organisme
qui toque chez vous une entreprise ou
quelque chose qui vous propose de faire
ce genre de programme
à partir du moment où les deux parties
sont au courant
à partir du moment où on est consentant
on connaît les règles du jeu et qu'on
accepte que mon conjoint et moi en
accepte c'est pas mal ça il y a pas de
fin moi je vois pas le problème en fait
la question mais si elle était avec un
homme
est-ce que tu comprennes la tentation
et inversement
c'est du courage moi je le ferai pas
c'est l'opération suffisent ça fait une
émission une belle maison intéressante
je suis d'accord c'est une opération
suicide
elle m'a fait changer
la liste dire est assez intéressante
dans la mesure où parfois on croit qu'on
a besoin d'un certain type de personnes
enfin et en fait on se trompe on a
besoin de quelqu'un plus complémentaire
par exemple deux personnes avec de
l'ambition parfois ça ne marche pas il
faut quelqu'un de complémentaire et donc
ce que vous venez de dire je trouve est
assez intéressant c'est vrai d'essayer
avec quelqu'un qui sur le papier nous
correspond plus parfois ne fonctionne
pas ou fonctionne mieux et donc on se
découvre mais pourquoi parler du mariage
c'est vrai aussi que Géraldine a raison
dans le sens où vous avez sûrement
participé aussi pour faire du buzz pour
gagner en notoriété des followers etc
mais c'est votre vous en avez le droit
voilà
c'est pas grave aujourd'hui je veux
juste dire un truc qu'il faut pas
oublier que Netflix c'est pas c'est pas
comme toutes les chaînes qu'on voit un
petit peu c'est quand même quelque chose
qui est très très sain il y a pas on
nous pousse pas à consommer de l'alcool
ou qu'on nous pousse pas embrasser
Pierpoljak en l'occurrence ici les films
pas c'est une expression belge
et je veux dire non on nous pousse pas à
la tromperie il y a pas de cons c'est
pas axé sur la tromperie le but il y a
vraiment un vrai concept derrière c'est
de savoir si on est vraiment avec la
bonne personne avec qui tu veux tu veux
finir tes jours et toi tu as compris
maintenant
non mais on peut rigoler mais j'ai
compris pas mal de choses grâce à cette
expérience je vous conseille je suis
sorti grandit de cette expérience
[Rires]
et au plus vite
que tu as compris il est trop fort non
j'ai compris pas mal de choses sur moi
sur mon couple et ce que je voulais dans
un futur je pense je pense que c'est
arrivé à pas mal de gens de faire des
erreurs de fouetter et soit la personne
décide de pardonner et on continue
ensemble et on en sort grandit on essaie
de tirer des leçons tout ça ou alors la
personne ne peut pas pardonner et
terminer ce bonsoir toi tu as envie que
tu as envie d'être pardonner
j'ai envie de j'ai envie de me
reconcentrer sur moi à ce moment là
c'est à dire et de savoir vraiment si à
ce moment-là si l'Insee c'est vraiment
la bonne personne parce que si j'ai des
si j'ai des tentations comme ça je sais
plus qui disent ça tout à l'heure mais
c'est que je suis pas dans quelque chose
qui est bon dans le couple donc il faut
absolument il faut absolument que je
réponde à ces questions c'est ça et
c'est pour ça que j'ai joué le jeu
peut-être un peu trop en question en
fait toi tu sais comme toi en fait c'est
j'ai été mort de rire de visiter
plusieurs appartements avant de trouver
le bon
et je devais être en haut parleur
Stéphane Plaza quoi non mais c'est ça
toi Lina moi j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses sur moi je pensais vraiment que
j'allais apprendre des choses sur mon
couple et
mais la vision du couple et la vie que
je voulais mener mais j'ai beaucoup plus
appris sur moi aussi vraiment tu as pris
quoi
bah j'ai appris que on pouvait perdre la
personne qu'on aimait à tout moment et
qu'il faut jamais prendre qui que ce
soit pour acquis mais vraiment moi je
suis allé là-bas je pensais vraiment que
Sofiane peut-être je sais pas de
problème il y avait pas de problème
qu'il allait changer d'avis ou autre
peut-être qu'il a fait je sais pas mais
au final je me suis rendu compte que non
rien n'était acquis
de groupe c'est qu'en fait on est le
seul responsable de son destin en fait
il y a pas en vouloir à pardonner ou pas
tout en fait mais là je suis sûr qu'on a
affaire à deux semaines
je suis sûr qu'on a à faire à 200 qu'on
a fait à deux célibataires
et j'ai pas vu le truc
je raconte
c'est celle en rose c'est pas elle avec
le tailleur je te vois avec la dame là
la deuxième c'est vrai que
là
il a raison tu as raison mais pas de
dire ça c'est une question de nez je te
vois qu'une femme comme ça aux réunion
alors la deuxième là cette jeune femme
parce que tu étais en recherche en
recherche de quoi d'amour oui tous les
jours je recherche de l'amour c'est
important l'amour au quotidien l'amitié
fait partie de l'amour etc mais pas en
recherche de mariage chez nous l'a dit
au début
non mais c'est une super émission il
tombe dans aucun piège de la téléréalité
moi quand j'ai vu le pitch je me suis
dit il va y avoir que des mecs
bodybuildés des filles en maillot de
bain ils vont tous s'échanger ils vont
se pécho pas du tout en fait ils se
donnent le Conseil entre eux pour moi
cette émission là on devrait la mettre
au-delà de Netflix on devrait la mettre
à la télé c'est ça qu'on veut
aujourd'hui c'est des émissions sincères
c'est comme Mario premier regard et ce
sera un carton ça n'a rien à voir avec
la partie où les anges allez regarder
les épisodes vous avez regardé et pour
les couples c'est vraiment super parce
que moi ça fait gagner du temps
l'expérience c'est comment c'est c'est
combien de temps ces trois semaines en
fait trois semaines avec le parc le
nouveau partenaire et on retourne deux
semaines avec notre ancien partenaire
pour comparer voilà au moins c'est bien
une semaine et une semaine on fait les
trois jours
un suicide vous avez dit tout à l'heure
ça veut bien dire ça veut bien dire que
déjà vous avez vos réponses c'est pas
moi
qui a parlé de suite
tu me dégoûtes alors que tu es sur snap
tu me dégoûtes tu me dégoûte pas du tout
en suicide moi je veux dire moi je veux
partir vraiment parce que déjà j'ai
relâché un boulot voilà mais bon voilà
non je peux pas forcément avec le
tournage
moi j'irai moi 25-30 ans vas-y
maintenant vas-y maintenant ils ont fini
la saison 2 toi
trois semaines dans trois semaines il
aura déjà trouvé quatre autres meufs
de trouver l'amour
il y a quand même une dernière chose que
je voudrais dire vraiment parce que j'ai
blessé une fille devant toute la France
entière devant beaucoup de pays au
Brésil en Espagne partout c'est dans le
monde entier donc moi ici devant tout le
monde je suis présenté mes excuses aussi
à l'INSEE parce que ça j'aurais pas dû
déraper j'ai merdé complètement je me
suis laissé emporter par par le jeu et
donc aujourd'hui j'ai le mérite
publiquement mais bravo c'est bien c'est
bien de le dire
[Applaudissements]